>> All right. Thanks
everybody for
coming back to our second panel,
it was so much fun
in the first panel,
I can't wait to see what
happens for the second one.
We're going to be hearing about
the frontiers of
machine learning,
which is a great segue
I think from
the topics that were
discussed in the last panel.
The moderator of this panel
is Kevin Leyton-Brown.
Kevin is a professor at
the University of
British Columbia and has spent
some time in the lab
on sabbatical,
so we all really
appreciate his expertise.
He has a lot of work at
the intersection of machine
learning and economics.
He has won the Edelman prize
for his work in
the FCC Spectrum options,
which he designed along with
his students and
Paul Milgrom to sell
spectra for the auctions,
the recent spectrum auctions.
So, with that, I'd like to
introduce Kevin Leyton-Brown.
>> Thanks very much. What's
really a joy to be here at
one of the great
meeting places in
our field for a really
interdisciplinary top-notch work.
Thank you so much for
having me and it's
also a joy to be here with
this distinguished panel.
So, I'd like to begin by asking
each member of the panel to
briefly introduce themselves,
briefly, and say something
about their affiliation and
their connection to
machine learning,
and then we'll dive in.
>> Hi. I'm Animoto Kumar.
I'm a professor at Caltech as
well as director of
machine learning.
Sorry, can you hear me now?
Hi. I'm Anima Anandkumar.
I'm a professor at Caltech
as well as the director of
Machine Learning
Research at Enridia.
I work at the intersections
of theory and
practice of machine learning.
I have a lot of
connections to this lab,
but this has been
such a nurturing atmosphere
in prime stages of my career.
Jennifer and Christian
have been amazing mentors.
Some of the early work,
the first work I did on
my core area of research
on tensors started here,
right in this building.
So, a lot of great
memories of this place
and it's amazing that it's
been 10 years. Congratulations.
>> So, I'm Victor.
>> We can't hear you
too. The mic is not on.
>> We're going to see whether
the learning panelists
can learn to turn their mics on.
We've had two training
examples now.
>> Is it on? Can you hear me?
>> No.
>> Is it on?
>> It's on.
>> Okay. While we
sort out that mic,
let's keep moving down
the line and we'll
come back to you.
>> Okay, yes.
>> All right, hello.
>> You bring it closer,
can you try that?
Now, I think it's on because
I hear it making noise.
I think we'll bring it closer.
>> Maybe I have to shout.
>> Yes.
>> I think the mics
are quite directional,
so if you have it
off to the side,
you're going to
have to be careful
not to look the other way.
It's a big group,
I know people in
the back really appreciate
the mics working.
Maybe you just hold it.
>> Yes, okay, yes.
>> Yes.
>> So, I'm [inaudible].
My main job is I work on,
I come from the MIT
economics department.
I also represent here
the Center for statistics
and data science,
which was created
several years ago.
I have been involved in
creation of various programs,
education programs,
and statistics.
My field is econometrics,
which are defined
as the intersection
of economics with
machine learning.
The field exists like it's
a 100 years old or so.
At the beginning,
the roots of the field
were always involved with
causal inference. The early.
>> I think your mic
is not working.
>> Let him try.
>> Yes?
>> Yes.
>> So, the first incantations
started to work on inference,
focus on problems, it was
in the context of
supply and demand,
and the field is defined by this.
To this day, this is one
of the most interesting,
exciting topics and areas
in machine learning.
I'll do a bit of
work in that area,
so some of the work of
the most exciting work for
my personal work I did
actually while visiting here
at Microsoft a
couple of years ago.
Some of this work with device
machine learning for
causal inference,
I did actually here in the labs,
I really appreciate it.
>> Hi, everyone.
I'm Lester Mackey.
I'm one of the newest
researchers here at
Microsoft Research,
New England. Hello.
>> They're switching you on.
>> Wow.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> Yes, that's.
>> Good. I'm Lester Mackey.
I'm one of the newest researchers
here at Microsoft
Research, New England.
I joined two years ago.
Before that, I was
a professor at Stanford
in statistics and
computer science.
My background's machine learning.
I work on methodology,
theory, modeling.
A lot of the problems I work on
these days stem from health care,
some weather and
climate forecasting,
high-energy physics,
the social good more broadly.
So, I'm glad to be here.
>> All right. Does my microphone
work out of the box?
They seem to be sabotaging
everybody else.
I'm trying to move away from
Lester because I think
his microphone is picking me up.
>> Sorry about that.
So, I'm Nicco Afuzi.
I'm a researcher
here in New England.
I joined this lab
now three years ago,
which seems longer.
As we were saying
last night at dinner,
time moves fast
when you have fun.
I've been having
fun, but still it
feels like more than three years.
>> You've done a lot.
>> Done some.
I'm a machine learning
researcher by training.
I got very interested in
computational biology,
so I worked a lot on
statistical genetics,
genome-wide association
studies methodology.
Then, I move to
functional genomics
with crisper gene editing.
Then, I went back to
machine learning working
on high-dimensional
busy optimizations,
which as you know under
the name has been rocked under
name of automated
machine learning now.
I think that the New
England lab is one of
the few places in the world
where one can move
from statistical genetics
to then doing some
crisper gene editing using
machine learning to
improve that obviously,
and then moving back
to machine learning
without serious
career consequences.
In fact, like moving
from field to field is,
I feel like it's encouraged.
So, yes, t's great to be here.
>> All right. Thanks everybody.
So, as you guys can see,
we're already modelling to
you the way we
intend to continue,
which is to be very informal.
Hopefully, maybe with
working microphones from now on.
So, we're going to
encourage the panelists
to make brief statements,
jump in as they see
fit on each question
to speak more than once to
each question if they so choose.
So, don't think that people are
being unruly and bold
when they do this,
this is the way we've
asked them to do it.
So, we're meant to be talking
about the frontiers
of machine learning.
It's no surprise that to any
of you here that machine
learning is having a moment
that computer science is
suddenly finding that
machine learning is an animating
principle of the decade,
and that so much is changing
about the way we work with
data and the way
systems are able to be
self-organized
based on that data.
It's almost a roadmap for
where our field is
going as a whole,
the way it positions itself
relative to machine learning.
So, we have a weighty obligation,
panelists to chart
the course here.
I'd like to begin by
thinking about the frontiers
by looking back.
So, I'd like to begin
by asking each of you,
with respect to your own work,
your own disciplinary
perspective,
to think about where you were
10 years ago with respect
to machine learning,
and what has happened in
the last 10 years that you
found personally surprising,
from the perspective of
breakthroughs in
machine learning.
>> Yes. I mean,
I can name quite a few
like 10 years ago,
I was barely at the
time of graduation.
It was also, in terms of
the overall conditions,
there was recession,
there were hardly any good jobs
in computer science and
that's what it seemed like.
So, I was so lucky to get
an academic job that taught
a new seer that, that year,
and now a decade later,
the opportunities for people
in machine learning are
just, seem endless.
There's so many great
positions in industry.
Every university wants to hire
more in machine learning.
So, in terms of opportunities,
it seems a lot.
>> So, you find the prospects for
employment in machine learning
is personal surprising?
>> It's not surprising but
there's been a very big shift,
and it has happened much
sooner than I thought,
and there has indeed
been progress,
what we thought in terms of,
can we train these
neural networks
at that scale and really
get up to these levels of
performance in practice?
That has been surprising
to everybody.
That's where I would like to been
on both extreme ends
of the spectrum,
I've done theory,
really thought deeply
about what machine learning
problems are hard?
What is the complexity
of these problems?
Being at Amazon and
know at N-Media,
I see extremely practical things
where we have to launch
a product very soon,
we have lots of
other constraints,
we have customers
having requirements.
So, you'll have to make due
with what's currently there,
you can't always think
about pushing the frontiers
in the next say,
five years or so.
So, being on the two sides,
what I've seen as we need
more research in
the middle ground.
I felt that in a way,
some of the theory was holding us
back because there was
a lot of pessimism.
There was even a paper in
my own field of tensors
with the title,
All Tensor Problems are NP-hard.
So, whenever I would
tell people about
my tensor algorithm and
our tensor method that we
were very excited about,
people would be
like, "But I thought
these are NP-hard problems. "
So, and it was a similar thing
with neural networks.
A lot of empirical researchers
for decades felt like they
were pulled away from it
because many people
thought it was impossible.
So, I have a lot of
respect for practitioners
and the early engineers
who really said,
"Let's just make it work.
Maybe it looks hacky,
maybe it's not.
It doesn't seem to follow
the principles but just let's
see how to make it work."
So, that's a great
starting point.
I have a lot of respect for
that and now the question is,
how do we nurture that
into a much bigger thing?
That's where we need
research on robustness,
on how to do it with less data,
how to do it in a lot
of different domains,
how to scale up the problem.
>> Let's not do the whole panel
in one question here.
>> Sorry.
>> We want to thank you.
Looking back last 10 years.
>> Yes.
>> As concretely as possible,
what's surprised you?
>> Go ahead.
>> So, 10 years ago,
I was starting my second year
of graduate school.
I was spending
about half of my time
working on legitimate research,
and half of it working on
this Netflix prize problem
that Netflix had
recently come up with,
it was to solve
their recommendation problem
and they would say,
"We would give you a million
dollars if you do that,
" so that was appealing
to a graduate student.
So, I remember thinking
just a year prior
when I was saying,
"Where do you go in private
school or what to do?"
I had flirted a bit with
a lot of this multi
computer science.
So, I spent sometime
researching
programming languages,
sometime researching theory,
and those both seemed
interesting to me
but nothing seemed to
be quite the right fit
and when I encountered
machine learning
actually via this Netflix prize,
this problem of, I see
what ratings you've given
movies in the past,
how can I predict to
what you're going
to rate a movie in the future.
I thought, " This is
perfect and this is
the future because
it combines people,
information for people about
the data they express,
It combines in
mathematical modeling,
give statistics and algorithms,"
all the best parts of
computer science and math,
and people to me.
I was just shocked by
the idea that, wow,
we can learn so much
about people from
their data and it want
us to explore that more,
and that's what got me
into that competition
but also into machine
learning to begin with.
So, this is not really an answer
to your question
because I would think,
I'm not at all surprised
about what's happened
to machine learning,
it seemed to me at that point
that this would be the future
that everyone should want
to be in this field.
It just seemed incredible,
and it seemed it really
had a lot of potential
both taking theory and
translating into practice,
and I think we're seeing
more and more of that.
>> Yes. So, one thing
that I think about,
so 10 years ago, I was in high
school now that's a joke.
But almost, it's close,
plus or minus five years.
So, if you think
about the machine
learning papers that
were accepted to
NIPS or top machine
learning conferences in
general, 10 years ago,
you would see a lot
of them were well,
at least in probabilistic
machine learning where
a graphical model put
distributions over things,
and then three
pages of gradients.
How do you learn the thing?
That was people got in,
got interested
probabilistic programming,
so a lot of that got automated.
But if you think about it,
in the course of 10 years,
we eliminated via
various techniques,
a bunch of those pages of papers.
So now, people will
take them for granted.
So, there was a very clear
process of make it work,
make it fast, and then
make it very easy to use.
If you look at the papers
that are submitted twice,
CLR, HCML, these days,
the build on this giant stack of
pretty solid, automated
complex work.
There are all these
probabilistic programming
libraries that you can use,
and you can just build more
complex constructs and concepts,
and models in
a fraction of the time.
I think that's paying
dividends for the field.
So, we are getting through
these crazy exponential
growth phase,
in terms of I feel
interesting measurable ideas,
that wouldn't have been
possible if we're still
all deriving gradients
for our beta model.
So, the first one I tried,
the first time I used
Theano which was coming
out I think from MILA maybe,
Theano was this library
that you would specify
variables and it would do
the gradients for you,
you could just specify
any model pretty much.
But it was slow,
at the first time I tried it
and then I tried it a year after,
it was faster, and now we have
crazy toolkits to do this work.
>> All right. Do you
want to speak to this?
>> Yes. So, 10 years ago,
we started to work on trying to,
essentially a financial variable,
a Russian model, where you
use machine learning tool that is
[inaudible] to proxy
the optimum instrument.
So, not many people know
the context here but yeah.
So, I think the Russian
is one of the main tools
[inaudible] metrics that
deals with pneumatic,
if you want to estimate
the demand or demand curve,
you need instruments to
shape the supply for
our alternative in
trade [inaudible] the moves of
the equilibrium quantity
along the demand curve.
So, we really need a good
instrument on machine learning,
to do a good instrument.
What was actually
fascinating at that time,
although many machine learning
tools without any theory.
If you press a button
would it work if
there is no theory?
This seemed to work amazingly
well, hard to imagine.
>> It will.
>> So, I saw that to do
some theoretical work
or theory around it,
focusing on how to find
the problems. [inaudible]
>> All right. So, still
looking 10 years back.
Let's now talk about what
you've thought would
be working by now
that turns out to be
a disappointing failure
as you see in marketing?
What in retrospect has
turned out to be
much harder than you
would though it would be?
>> I thought an answer and
then I thought, "Maybe not".
>> But here you go.
>> All right. Please
don't throw stuff at me.
Reinforcement learning. No, okay.
So, I think when I
first started looking into
reinforcement learning,
I thought, we are,
almost it's one of
those times where you think,
I'm out about basically
out of a job.
People are figuring
out, as we speak,
and so by the time
I end up contributing something,
it's going to be sold.
That hasn't been the case.
So, in some sense, people are
making a lot of progress,
but there's still
a lot of work to do,
and in some sense, it's
getting interesting now.
>> I remember being at
a NIPS workshop on the frontiers
of reinforcement learning
15 years ago,
that was everybody been moaning
the fact that there was
almost nothing realistic
that you could
do with reinforcement learning.
That certainly has changed.
The reinforcement learning
has come a long way.
>> We really nailed
the cart pole.
>> A lot of games. That's all.
No. I mean, I do think,
there's still realistic
applications.
There have been
very few real use cases
of deep reinforcement learning,
especially the ones that scale.
So, I mean it's
perfectly fine to say we
can solve games that are
hard for humans by
training on billions of
examples but it's a very
different ball game to ask.
How would we solve robotics?
How would we automate
manufacturing?
How would we really do
automated machine learning
at the end of the day.
The holy grail is ultimately,
they reborn backyards
in their homes,
people without even
thinking keep training and
personalizing
their different AI tools
and frameworks and say,
their personal devices,
in their home,
or at work, and
that's a long way.
In light right now, I mean,
it has become a lot easier
than what it was 10 years ago.
The software frameworks
have gotten amazingly good.
The computational scale has
been growing every day.
We're even close to breaking
the exascale barrier.
So, the progress there has
been amazing, but there is still,
I think algorithmic
progress to be
done to ask how we
can exploit that,
to make it more seamless,
to go from raw data to answers,
to a fully working AI system
with almost no intervention.
We are so far from
that dream today.
>> So, what other really
concrete technologies,
working use cases would
you have expected
10 years ago that
you're surprised
not to have seen
progress on today?
>> In this is a case where
we've had a lot of progress,
but I'm surprised that we
haven't solved these problems.
So, I think there are lots
of opportunities for using
machine learning very
profitably in healthcare,
but for the large part,
a lot of problems that
are essentially
prediction problem,
which is like bread and
butter machine learning.
Supervised learning
problems classified as
patient as someone's going to
respond or not stratified
this patient in
the following way,
but the major barrier is
actually data collection.
We have small dataset
of patients that are
heavily guarded.
We don't have any good way of
aggregating them across centers,
different people with
different features
but no standardization.
That's what put them
on those principles of
barriers to solving
a lot of these problems,
making a lot of headway.
In the cases that I think
when we had had a big
successes are when
institutions spend
a lot of time and effort
pulling their data
together to get a data
better solutions.
So, I found it surprising.
>> Cool. By the way, Lester,
if you hold your mike a
little lower down. Yes.
>> [inaudible] to
your right. Yes.
>> Well, let Jeff
help you out then.
So do you wanna
speak [inaudible].
Oh, there we go.
You've got upgraded. Okay?
>> Now, I'm off. I'm good?
Alright, it's back on?
Apple, can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Good. It's very important.
So, talking about health care,
one thing that comes to mind is,
so working in Combion,
the intersectional
Combion medicine,
what I've seen is, describing
your uncertainty over
your predictions
is super important.
Yet in healthcare applications
particularly, split
in two fields,
either poor predictors
that give you
uncertainty estimates that are
calibrated and they're useful,
but then they're so wide.
They are very really actionable,
or you got these very
good predictors,
but then we cannot estimate nice
calibrated uncertainty
estimates from them.
So, that's a big challenge
for us because in
some sense the data doesn't
come until people see
the usefulness,
clinicians in particular.
It was, when I was in the UK,
I was sitting in
this meeting where there was
the Health Care Regulatory
Agency and they we're thinking of
using machinery and
that was in 2013, 2012.
They were not thinking of
using machine learning,
but I couldn't, they
were like, "Okay,
so we know we can use
machine learning,
but how do we know it's useful?".
Because always you can develop
personalized interventions
and we're like,
"We already do. We
look at the patients".
But instead nobody's are new med,
these are informed by
data and they say,
"Well, we are informed by data
where we have case studies".
So, it was a hard sell
and until we show that there
are these predictors give
you nice predictions
that you can throw
error bars around and
it's going to be hard.
>> I agree with that completely.
I think we have
a big evaluation problem
machine learning.
This is something
that people think
about in statistics all the time
and I talk about it all the time.
Much less than machine
learning and it's
even a bigger problem like
it's just a small data.
You spend a lot of
your time thinking about
big data that has
lots of challenges.
But small data has
some very different sorts
of challenges and one of
them is just wrapped
up in evaluation for
instance and I can't even
withhold data to tell,
how well my method is doing,
but how do I know
if this is working,
and how can I prove
to someone that
this is going to be
useful for their field.
We often rely on things
like cross validation
but how good is possible.
This is something, this is
I think a surprising thing,
people been using
cross-validation forever.
Decades before I got to
grad school using
cross-validation,
we still don't know how it works.
We don't know. It's probably
a good estimate of
the thing it's estimating.
It's only under this very extreme
circumstances that we know that.
Basically, we know it's
good at training error.
Is this a good estimate
of your error?
That's a huge open question
that still looking for an answer.
It's still unanswered,
but we still use it,
left and right in the chamber.
>> I would, sorry.
>> Please.
>> I would add to
that like saying
I know what I'm
surprised just, we,
as a research community
how little we've
been able to enforce
reproductibility
and really asking
if this progress like
the claim progress in
the papers is real, right?
Especially in
reinforcement learning.
My job has a long list
of papers which were
not reproducible.
When I say,
reinforcement learning,
I mean the more recent deep
reinforcement learning papers,
right? To clarify.
Because they run that scale,
I mean there are runway
just so few
initializations there is.
The court is sometimes
not even released,
the hyperparameters
are not released.
So, I'm just surprised
that how we as
a community are not able
to either put this down into
our conferences and say,
if you're claiming a result you
really have to back it up.
>> Just one point
towards that though.
So, lets say that people release
hyperparameters code
and architecture,
whatever they are doing which
is the case for princes,
for something we're
working on which
is neural architecture search.
How do you find the architecture
of the neural networks?
So, some of the comparisons
that we need to perform,
take 3,160 days,
GPU days to pick.
Okay, so Microsoft maybe we
can think of landmine GPU and
just for 3,000 days
and just crunch on it.
But broad reproducibility,
I think it's limited
now by computations.
So, maybe in video we should.
>> Any last words Victor,
before we move on?
>> Yes. I would say there are
multiple disappointments as well
as simultaneous opportunities.
So, one is the disappointment as
Louie just discussed [inaudible].
Yes, it's cross-validation.
People who are using
it, they don't know
why it works, how it works,
that's the one.
[inaudible].
>> Anything about deep learning,
like in the theories, is
also like a big puzzle,
like expressive properties of
the deep maths,
the itinerization properties.
There is a lot of work, but we're
still very far from [inaudible].
>> Thanks. Okay. So, now I'd
like to ask all of you to
think into the arbitrary future.
What do you think
the most surprising things that
Machine Learning will
ultimately be able to do,
that right now Machine Learning
isn't making much headway with?
What do you think are the limits
of progress in Machine Learning,
the biggest Machine Learning
dreams that we should have?
>> I would say neuro programming,
like ultimately, when
I do neuro research.
Ultimately, Go-machines
would be able
to program themselves based
on what they observe.
So, there may be
some axioms that are given
and some initial training,.
But then, after that,
they can interact,
and they can really
come up with laws,
and inferences, and make
new hypotheses, go back,
do further experiments,
and to do that in all
different fields,
like how we think
about the universe,
how we think about
the laws of physics,
how we discover new materials.
I mean, there is still
a distant future,
but that will be
an exciting future.
>> I think neural
boy bands will follow the-
>> Don't those exist already?
>> Neural boy bands.
I think a lot of
our music will be
generated by Machine Learning,
and we'll actually
like to listen to it.
I think that's coming.
Watch for it. I'm
going to defend it.
>> Already publicly
disclosed it, big enough.
I think Machine
Learning on memory and
CPU-constrained devices is
completely underexploited
right now.
I saw an intern this summer.
She was really a current keen.
She was really into drones,
and she gave me one of
those drones of the Internet.
I don't want to infer the cost,
but I think $20
drone or whatever.
That drone does
very simple things.
Basically, it has no real CPU
that you can think of,
but imagine deploying
a super, simple,
deep reinforcement learning
model on that drone,
you could do
very interesting things.
If you can deploy machinery
models in tiny devices,
now the spectrum of applications
expands incredibly.
People are thinking of putting
many devices in your toilet
to measure microbiome.
Maybe not connected to WiFi,
just keep them offline.
But there are so many
interesting applications,
and that right now,
we're doing huge scale
Machine Learning
with Teraflops of power,
but you can imagine
the smaller Microflops.
>> All right, Victor. We've got
boy bands and smart toilets.
What else do we have?
>> [inaudible].
>> All right. So, anybody
else want to jump in on that,
we'll let you to say
more than one thing.
But if not all, I'll move on.
You've been a really a bundle
of contradictions about
deep reinforcement
learning, where do you-
>> I want to the balance the- I
just should provide
a balance there,
but we're thinking 2050,
2060. So, it will work.
>> Hope springs eternal. Okay.
>> We think of it already.
>> Exactly. I think, I mean,
you guys are dreaming big enough.
>> Oh, I forgot about that.
>> What about the trick
with some [inaudible]?
>> Okay. So, let's not steal from
the next session as
we're being warned.
So, having talked about
the amazing things that we
might someday be able to do,
machines that can
program themselves,
boy bands that can
program themselves.
What other things- toilets.
I wasn't going to go there again.
We all remember that. What do you
think of the things that the
fundamental limits of
Machine Learning are?
What are the things that
Machine Learning really is
never going to be able to do?
That really, it'll stop
being Machine Learning when
certain problems that are
still within scope for
Computer Science really
will never be part of ML?
>> I mean, I don't
think there is a limit.
If we think between
Machine Learning and
Artificial Intelligence.
Between the terminologies
stuff people
have that differentiation, right?
But if you don't, if
you just talk about,
if we can say have
an adaptive system that can
really understand
the environment around it and
keep learning and keep adapting,
I don't see any limits
when we get there.
>> Well, I guess I
want to encourage you
to think about Machine Learning
narrowly rather than anything
that might be called
Artificial Intelligence,
because I think that
makes it too easy.
So, I really want to think
about learning from data,
maybe as distinct from reasoning.
>> Got it.
>> I think there- I mean,
the limits are precisely
the data itself.
Like, it's garbage
in garbage out.
So, it's really then up
to the researchers
and engineers to ask,
the experts in that domain to ask
what is the data that's
relevant to this task?
How do I specify the task?
What is the objective function?
How do I evaluate it?
That's inherently
the limitations too,
because those could
keep changing,
and it gets harder and harder to
seamlessly adapt
to different ones.
There may be
conflicting objectives,
how do we reconcile all that.
>> Thoughts from the rest of you?
You don't have to keep
going in the same order,
but you can if you want.
>> I agree with that
completely. I think
the biggest limit
is just going to be
the data that we've collected,
the data that we present
to our algorithms.
I imagine this will
come up again in
a future panel, but we see that.
If you do it with
the bias dataset,
you're only going to be learning
about those same biases.
You're incorporating those biases
into your learned models.
I think this has become
more and more important
as we think about
interpretability,
because that in essence
is a human concept.
When we say interpretability,
we mean that you,
some person is able
to interpret this,
and we know what that
means to a person.
We have to query that person.
We have to query
that field often.
Then, what's been
incorporating that
into our algorithms as well,
we can't really solve
the interpretability problem.
In all the cases
where I've had to
deal with training
Machine Learning models,
and then handing them
off to someone in
a field that's supposed to
be benefiting from this,
I'm asked, "What does this mean?
Why does these
predictions being made? "
Inevitably I have to work with
that person to understand
what the model's doing.
I think we can push a
little bit further and
producing models that tend
to be easier to interpret.
But I think without that extra
human element, and hence,
also the data produced
by those people,
it's a lost cause.
>> Yeah. Something that I
might say in addition
to the data,
was deciding the
objective function,
and that's, from my own work
in computational biology,
that turned out to be where
I spent most of my time.
Yes, the data was one.
Maybe 30 percent of the time,
and that's 70 percent was
what are we trying
to optimize for,
because we have
great function approximators.
The Machine Learning, you
want to learn a function.
If you have the right data,
you will learn the function.
The problem is that, how
do you define what
you want to learn.
I was on Twitter
last night, and somebody,
[inaudible] as you do.
There was somebody who was
training an agent to walk.
Basically, the system could
design the length of the legs,
and the articulations, and
the speed at which it works.
Basically, the
objective was to reach
a goal line after many obstacles.
Basically, the system
without constraints,
just designed super long legs,
that basically made
the entire agent
collapse at the end. [inaudible]
>> So, objective achieved.
It's like the Reward 100.
So, then they start constraining
the length of the legs,
and now it does skipping,
but this is the problem, right?
If you just let it go on
an objective function
without thinking,
it will just find shortcuts.
There was a thing like
were there was a rocket.
Another one of
those tight fragments
problems was designing
a rocket that goes up and then
lands in another location.
So, what the system
found without constraints
from physics,
was if you go underground,
it's actually
consumes less energy.
So, it actually
designed the rocket to
just point down and just dig.
>> Yeah. So, what should
we take from this?
>> A lot of my work now is about
automating and automated
Machine Learning.
As much as I want that kind
of result to be achieved,
I think the human
will still need to be
the entity that decides
what you're learning,
directing the learning
towards something.
And so, that's I think
something that we'll
never probably automate
or solve completely.
Because especially if you specify
an objective the system will
do anything to achieve it.
And now, you start specifying
too many constraints and then
you have other problems.
So, that's a big problem that I
may be due to lack of
imagination cannot see
how it'll be solved.
>> And to add to that,
I think even some of
the critical failures
that'll come about and
that have come about
will be more human failures
than the machine-learning or AI.
In the media, it'll
be easy to say,
"Oh, look AI failed."
The famous one is
the Uber accident,
of the you know where.
The pedestrian was actually
detected by the sensors,
so it was not
a technological failure.
But it was a failure
in terms of how
the processing did not
reach the end decision.
Right? And so, if the system
was extensively tested,
it would have been
definitely caught,
because there is,
we all know about
false alarm and detection curve.
So, we can ask where are
we in that operating?
What is the operating point
in that curve?
And then make a
decision based on that.
So, in this case,
either it slipped through
or it was decided
that we would just
have this human driver
who would just
take care of any failure
of Machine Learning.
But that's again, not taking into
account the human attention span.
So, if they're continuously
driving forever
and the chances of
failure are tiny,
but when they happen
they're catastrophic.
So, I think we'll
still face a lot of
challenges in
many such domains where
AI system will be in
the loop with the critical
decision-making and even having
human or many humans may
not be the solution.
>> Well, so, Niccolo and Animah,
both in your last
responses raised
this idea of how people
were going to be
reacting in real time to deployed
ML systems and I think
this really touches
on this question of
the limits of ML.
It seems like right now,
we haven't gotten very good
socially at understanding
these limits and understanding
the boundaries of where
these systems break down,
how we ought to
interact with them.
Do you guys think
this is something
that we're going
to get better at?
Do you think the systems
are going to have to
adapt in a way to make it
easier for us to do this?
If so, do you have
any thoughts on what
that might look like?
Are things going to get worse as
these systems get
more widely deployed?
>> Possibly, yeah. There are
people working on it,
but there is still,
compared to the size
of the problem and
the size of the Machine
Learning field,
there is a very narrow
contact surface in between,
which is HCI work,
Human-Computer Interaction.
So, things such as
understanding and
visualizing uncertainty,
providing it as a feedback to
the to the human operator or
the human making decision.
It's still something
that is poorly
understood and to be developed.
There is some there is some work,
but it's very specific.
Last night at dinner
I was talking about,
there is an app called Dark
Sky that does nowcasting
of the weather,
which is very useful in Boston
because you don't
want to get soaked.
And it predicts basically
a time series of rain intensity.
And uncertainty estimate is
super important because people,
and there is
a whole book about it
which actually are
social media collective,
which was about following
the National Weather Service and
studying how they think
about uncertainty
and predictions,
it's called Masters of
Uncertainty.
So, for weather prediction,
conveying uncertainty about
your prediction is super
important and this time series,
the way the app does it,
it shows basically
a smooth Gaussian process
looking line that shows
the boundaries of
the uncertainty.
And stuff like that is
absolutely brilliant,
because it allows you to
understand what's going on,
but it's very narrowly focused on
some domains right now and we
need more contact surface.
>> But it seems like it allows
you to know what's going on if
you're already very good at
thinking about uncertainty.
It seems like, but the
broad population has
a lot of trouble thinking about
probabilistic statements.
Are we going to get better as a
society because we
are going to be so
surrounded by these things or are
the systems going
to have to adapt?
>> I think we will need to
get more educated about it.
So, for instance,
for the elections,
the New York Times
is another version
of these uncertainty
estimates things,
where you have a dial that goes
Republican or Democrat and they
added like a jitter to show
the uncertainty around.
Exactly, the jitter,
in the beginning,
was terrifying and
then it turned out,
and it was going from
side to side showing
broad uncertainty estimates and
so people actually turned it off.
And the most recent,
I think it was the midterms,
not the midterms, but the
filling the vacancies.
The New York Times didn't
have it anymore I think.
So, people just has to be.
>> We shouldn't discuss politics,
and we do that in our peril
but see, there we go.
>> You see.
>> But I'm reminded of
the last presidential election,
where at the last minute
Clinton was forecast to win
by something like 70-30 and
then when the unexpected
thing happened,
everyone said, how were
the polls so wrong?
It's like well, sometimes
30 percent probability things
happen. It seems like.
>> It happened exactly.
>> Maybe if you have
a well-calibrated model they
should be happening
30 percent of the time.
>> Exactly, I feel
really like that.
>> Somehow people
don't even seem to
think that way even
about binary choices.
So, what hope do we have
about richer model spaces?
>> I don't have an answer.
Does anybody else?
>> Further, I think it's
going to be harder if
you assign a human-like
nature to the system.
So, especially robots or
things that looked like
a human ride out car,
that you think is being driven
by a human but it's not.
So, you tend to assign
the same qualities and
the same behavioral
response from a human.
So, there I think a lot of,
maybe even if we give
uncertainty estimates,
you kind of ignore all that
and you just go back to how
you would expect a human to
react and I think that's
even more dangerous.
>> Well, I guess this comes
back to your notion before of,
objective functions and
also the point that Victor
brought up before about
causal reasoning,
about really being able to
ascribe some causal motivation.
It seems to me that
this is another place
where Machine Learning
has been very fruitful,
but also where there's an
inherent tension
about reasoning from
data because you want
to understand something
counterfactual,
you don't necessarily
want to understand
only what the data
has to tell you.
Is there an inherent limit there?
>> Yeah. So, it's
especially interesting how
different fields think about
the same questions in
a very different way.
So, I spent two days
in Tubingen with
Bernhard Scholkopf, and so,
his lab is devoting
all of its attention
out to questions of
Causal Inference and then
they want out to automate
the causal discoveries.
But it seems like
it's really hard
to do so without
contextual knowledge,
without experts being
brought in and so on.
Just this really simplistic
approach of saying let's assume
that we have a diag or
something like this,
a diagram without cycles and
then they just discover it,
it often goes wrong,
like it would go wrong
in supply-demand systems
because it's not really
a diag and so on.
And without knowing the context,
I think it could
go terribly wrong.
So, I don't know how to
automate this and so on.
People mentioned here
quantification of uncertainty here,
I don't think we all agree on
what the uncertainty means.
I would be surprised, again,
if somebody has
a good quantification
of uncertainty for
Deep Neural Nets.
If you have a prediction
for based on them,
I would be interested in seeing
a confidence interval,
the classical one.
The frequentist one
just to be clear.
It's even for prediction,
the counterfactual prediction
is much much harder
because we have to
create unbiased signals
about the treatment effects
or causal effects
and the constructions of
session by signals often
relies on experiments.
Experiments are not available for
the most interesting research
questions that we have.
The experience can be used
to measure short-run
effects that give you
an idea about the true causes,
but we're so far away
from learning long-run effects
and from automating the learning.
>> All right. This is
the first thing that spurred
our audience,
spontaneous activities.
>> I think going back to
your question about how will we
adapt to this
basically new world,
I think we have to.
But when I say we, I really mean
the younger generation
because we are old.
It's a new world.
>> Why do you so little faith
in the older generation.
>> It's a new world, we're old,
but I think there is
hope for education.
I think a lot of universities are
already starting to integrate
statistical education into
the standard curriculum
for all students.
I've seen Data Science
101 courses popping
up at places like
Stanford and Berkeley.
I think we need to
go farther back
than that because
now we already have,
I mean, these systems
are being deployed.
We already have Machine Learning
systems that are just
helping to decide who's going
to get released on bail.
It's affecting your life
your life and what's
going to happen,
will you end up in jail or
released with your family?
And that's going to
happen more and more.
So, it means
the new generations will
have to be educated
on these things.
So, I think it is
difficult to take someone
like me and to
be retrained into thinking
about uncertainty,
but I think if we
start early we can.
>> So, we shouldn't
even have faith in
former stats professors
from Stanford?
There's no hope for
the rest of us.
>> Point estimates,
catch them early.
That should be the public health.
>> So, should calculus in
high schools be
replaced by statistics?
>> Yes.
>> Augmented.
>> Augmented, I would say.
>> Now, what are you
going to kick out?
>> Calculus.
>> You can't say augmented.
>> Stochastic calculus. Yeah.
>> It's the best kind.
>> I like that.
>> Okay. So, we've talked
a bunch about the limits of ML,
both how ML's going to grow,
and also what maybe ultimately
is going to constrain it.
If we imagine that all of
our machine learning
dreams are realized,
machine learning takes
its appropriate place at
the center of computer science,
ruling the world,
what other areas of
computer science
and maybe of the sciences
more generally are going
to increase in importance,
because of their
inherent complementarity
to the place the machine
learning will ultimately reach.
I think this is particularly
important given that,
MSL New England is
such an interdisciplinary place.
So, we're here really to
celebrate MSL New England,
and I think in the interdisciplinary
lab of the future.
If you're going to
be centered on ML,
who else do you need to
make sure you have around?.
>> I mean. So, at
Caltech as well,
it's a very interdisciplinary
place, right?
We recently launched
AI for science
with the goal of
really having AI,
make an impact in
all areas of sciences.
So, to me yes,
there should be a central
overarching machine learning
affecting all the fields,
but ultimately it
also has to bring in
all the domain experts
and to transfer some
of the machine learning
knowledge to them,
and for them to also further
develop machine learning.
So it's not going to be a few of
machine learning researchers just
solving all the world's problems.
I think that would be
also too arrogant to
think that a few of
us could do that,
but instead, they would really
be machine learning itself
getting democratize,
spreading its wings and
the basic grounding is present
for all sciences in fact,
all areas of education
including the arts.
Then it's up to every researcher
in every field to say,
''I know how is this going to be
relevant to me and how
can I further develop,
what are the domain
constraints I have,
is it the small data regime,
is it the large data,
is it the interactive learning,
is it mostly online learning."
So, all these, like it
what aspect is really
relevant to my field
and how do I value it.
So, we have to really broaden
machine learning rather
than centralized it.
>> When I was graduate
student at Berkeley,
I was part of
this interdisciplinary lab
which was called the Rad Lab.
So, it was essentially
machine- it
was a system's plus
machine learning lab,
but the goal of
the machine learning piece
was to develop
machinery that are
useful for systems.
By the end of my time
in graduate school,
I had been replaced by
new lab called the AMPLab,
and again it was
the Systems Engineering Lab
and then it was
about building systems that
will support machine learning.
I think that's been
the crucial part two
of scaling up machine learning,
dealing with all the big
data problems that we have,
making use of
parallel processing,
dealing with cloud computing.
So, systems in particular,
I think is one of the good.
I think there are a number
of answers, but that's
one particular area that we need.
>> I think that that would
have been one of my answers to
the first question
about what's been
surprising in the last 10 years,
is the extent to which the
breakthroughs in ML had been,
systems breakthroughs, rather
than the theory breakthroughs.
>> I should say GPU serving.
>> That's a soft spot
for you, for sure.
>> Well, probably it's
easy to see because
it's such a strength
of the New England lab,
but the combination of
quantitatively minded people and
qualitatively minded people
is a powerful one.
So, I think humanists around
and engaging with them,
is a crazy powerful combination
and because sometimes machinery
it's easy to get
tangled up in just,
I can answer this
so why not do it.
Sometimes it's useful to
direct your attention to
what should you really answer,
not just because you can,
but it is because you should.
Those usually are
the harder questions
that are more profound,
and it's useful to have people
who be view in those ideas.
>> To comment too
along that line.
So, I know these days I give
talks to broad audiences
and also around the world,
really reach out to people
but maybe not having
the math background,
and so many of them very like,
how do I participate in this
machine learning revolution?
How do I- I want to learn
but where do I start?
So, that's been
another great thing that
our efforts like fast RTI
and other community efforts that
are really making it
easy for people to,
not only deploy machine learning,
but to write simple code,
to have very accessible examples
and I think it's
so crucial that we
make the education about
machine learning and
through Kerala even math.
Like much more accessible to
broad population who maybe
thinking in different ways.
That's the only way we're
going to make progress
by involving humanity in
creating better
machine learning and
designing better even forms
of machine learning.
>> So, yeah. I would
like to give comment,
I think online education
is important.
I could say, I've
benefited a lot from
Andrew Ing's course
in deep learning,
I just love the
programming and so on.
Very easy to for a busy person
it's really nice too.
Second, I think, the community
is really important,
I really enjoyed
my time with MSR,
you have great community
really open-minded people,
coming from different fields
and working together,
discussing and breaking
language barriers
and so on, that was fantastic.
In some ways, what we have now at
the Center for statistics
and Data science is
very similar in nature,
you have different people
coming from
different departments,
working in stats in machine
learning, broadly defined.
We created educational programs
like minor in stats,
dual PhD program in
exons statistics,
mathematics and statistics or
economics and
statistics and so on.
I think we have the best seminar,
I believe it's called stochastic
in statistics seminary,
I really love the seminar.
Lots of people come in,
it's really nice
presentations with theorems
improve and so on [inaudible].
We, yeah, started this new
under graduate program which
is Bachelor of Science
in Computer Science Economics
and Data science.
So, I think that's going to
be game changer for us at least.
>> So, to connect
something that came
up in a lot of
your different answers,
I particularly liked what
Nicholas said about
humanists being
useful to this broader
enterprise of machine learning.
You maybe connecting
to what Lester was
saying about the new generation,
but imagine that you're
an aspiring academic in
some area that you're
never going to be
a machine-learning researcher,
but you believe that machine
learning is going to
be a really important part
of the future,
maybe you're a social scientist,
maybe you're a theorist,
maybe you're a scientist
in some other discipline.
What do you need
to do differently
compared to maybe
the generation of
academics before you in
your own discipline to
be better positioned,
to be working as
part of this machine
learning enterprise,
to be working
alongside ML people?
>> The very first is the data.
So, I would say, are
you able put together the data
that's there in the field,
maybe it's in disparate forms
and maybe there's even
missing ones, but
at the very least,
can you try to bring that
all together and ask
by combining the data sets
and even collecting new data,
can I really now answer
questions I couldn't before.
I'm working with
the machine learning scientists,
I think it has to be
a close collaboration,
because that's the only way
both sides can learn
from each other.
So, those are the two
things I would say.
>> Yeah, I agree with that
and I think the only
thing I would add
was probably trying to
get a job from Jennifer.
>> Working together on problems,
you have a scientist that has
a domain knowledge
and has a problem.
He or she should be
able to approach and
talk a machine-learning scientist
to help solve the problem.
There should be
a common educational base
to be able to speak to get
on the same page quickly.
>> Then, I guess I want to open
that box a little bit though.
I don't just want to talk
about the value of talking
together or the value of
having to drop from Jennifer,
I want the recipe for having
to drop from Jennifer.
What is the skill set that
people are going to need?
What are they going to have
to actually develop as
a toolkit to be able
to engage in those
collaborations usefully?
>> So, at Caltech,
we have now a new
Data Science major and
minor that's across
campus anybody can take.
So the minor, especially.
So, I think augmenting like
the core area are
the core major with
a minor in Data Science would be
a great start because you
have the fundamentals.
If you are out of school too,
do the online courses too,
I tell a lot of
candidates that I get who
want to get into
machine learning,
I point them to the resources.
These Jupyter
Notebooks are great,
they have explanations
but they also
have working code
to really hands-on,
tried on different datasets,
explore the failure modes.
I think that's what really
distinguishes somebody with
a surface knowledge
of machine learning
and somebody who is deeper is,
okay, why are things
failing, how do I debug,
how do I resolve
that and to participate
in online forums,
I mean there's just
so much activity happening
online and even in
meet-ups and workshops.
So, there's a lot of
community-driven efforts and I
think being part of it
would be a great start.
>> Yeah. Let me
give you an example
that I've seen with my own eyes.
During my PhD, I was in
the Institute for
Transition Neuroscience.
So, we were
a machine-learning group
embedded with biologists.
These biologists
received training,
some of them like 10 years ago,
12 years ago at the time.
They went through
stats and math courses
and basic computer science
courses but for a lot of them,
it was not a core coursework.
So, it was just pass or fail.
Yeah, you passed stats, good job.
So, then they realized and
then there was this
machine-learning group and
our goal was to work at
the intersection of fields.
They would come with
their microarray data,
at the time it was microarrays.
They would say,
"Okay, I will need
to understand
differential expression
between a brain tissue that
has the disease and
brain tissue that doesn't
have the disease."
Being machinery people,
we pop something,
calculate the p-value
and whatnot.
Then they realized that
the turnaround time was long,
that we maybe didn't
super look at
calibration of the p-values,
that sometimes when
you fit things,
you do multiple comparisons,
we were controlling but you
could control in better ways.
So then they'll say, "Okay,
so these people are busy,
they're doing
their machinery papers.
Why don't we pick
it up ourselves?"
So, they started getting
the wrong training stats
and we rapidly found
that once they got
these training stats,
they would be super
competitive with what
we could come up with.
We can basically get
95 percent all the
way there but because
they had the training,
then they could communicate
more effectively with us,
what if with their wishes
were from the system.
At that point, there was
this feedback loop where we can
understand better what
they were looking for,
they understood better
what our models were
doing and so they learn
more machine learning,
we learn more biology.
That was like a virtual cycle.
>> I'm a bit
surprised that so far the
answers you guys are giving are
about how people in
other disciplines
should learn some machine
learning themselves,
instead of you-
>> No, I said stats,
not machine learning.
>> Oh, stats but you should
learn the toolkit that
I know people have to
meet in the middle.
I guess as you're wearing
an economics hat,
I'm particularly excited by
the idea of compliments.
What are entirely
different things
where people might lean in
an opposite direction to really
develop a skill set that I
know people don't have but
that's going to be
really relevant
in a world with
a lot of ML people?
>> Human interaction.
So, I think that I mean
to be more serious,
it'll be really
important in the future.
So, it's not just
a mathematical ability
but to communicate
to different areas to empathize
with the difficulties,
the different sections
of population have
or different fields
or phasing so how
we can learn from others to
help solve better problems.
>> This was a tough
question because it
was a many-to-one relation.
If you define the set of all
possible other fields
and then you say,
"What's the compliment that
machinery doesn't have?"
It's a really tough
set to define.
So, I don't have an answer.
>> Well, you're almost out
of time, so fair enough.
>> Well, I say I feel
like machine learning is
largely like a field
of immigrants.
I mean, being
a pretty young field.
A lot of these people came in
from other disciplines
in computer science,
or mathematics, from
physics quite often.
I guess say I can disagree with
the rest of the question
and then I do think
the best thing for them is to
go and learn machine learning
too and then augment
their own skill set with that.
Yeah, that's how I'd approach it.
>> Well, if I can't get you
to disagree with each other,
at least I can get you
to disagree with me.
So, we're just in
the last seconds left.
Let me just invite
you each to give
some closing thoughts
if you have any.
How do we get there from here?
What are the things we should all
be focusing on as a group
to realize the vision that we
spent the last hour
talking about?
>> I mean for me, it
would be bridging
theory and practice to ask,
what are the current
blind spots in practice?
Can we design better algorithms?
Also, really explore
the failure modes
of those algorithms
and keep iterating.
So, it's always go on
but to make it much
more of a process
that's easy to do and
to focus more on data.
>> At least for me,
the most important things
is breaking gaps between
theory and practice,
there's just a gigantic
gap out there.
The second is breaking
communication barriers.
There's a lot of
Data Science activities,
we need to understand
each other better.
>> Yeah, I'd like to see
a broader dissemination
of problems.
I think research seems
to be a bit myopic.
We come up with a problem,
we try to solve it ourselves,
we can't solve it,
we shelve it and
the problem dies,
or maybe it's rediscovered
a decade later.
Quite often, we might
know what the problems are
but not the right solutions.
In our current environment,
it's very easy
to reach out to
the broad community.
We already start to
see this with machine
learning competitions,
for instance,
where someone knows there's
a particular problem
that needs to be solved.
They're willing to
put out lots of
money so somebody
else can solve it,
and you end up finding solutions
from places where you
wouldn't normally look,
often from different disciplines.
I think that's probably
the way forward to making
the biggest contributions
to humanity, broadly.
>> My main point is we should be
worrying more about the
good scholarship in
machine learning.
So, there is this great paper
that is on archive,
which is troubling trends
in machine-learning scholarship.
We are not always doing
a great job disentangling,
for instance, the sources of
an empirical game in performance.
We should be thinking
more about that.
So, people should read
that paper and think about it;
it's a very interesting concept.
>> Great, let's thank
all of our panelists
for the enlightening facts.